s.a.t is going digital one local
tutoring consultant says the move is
daunting as many kids are already facing
challenges learning online but as mary
jane belliesa shows us how tutoring is
helping with college preparation the
pandemic has disrupted the education
system creating a learning gap leaving
teachers and parents to find other
options here at cultivate academics
founder rebecca davis is helping high
school seniors get up to speed as they
prepare for their college admissions
what we're really seeing is a lot of
gaps in math and science content that
just seems to be a bit more difficult to
learn online davis says high school
seniors have been scoring a lot lower on
tests due to the switch to remote
learning in the last year i think
teachers rightly so were attempting to
you know make sure that just the most
foundational concepts were covered you
know and making sure that students felt
engaged and whatnot and so a lot of the
higher level learning just kind of
naturally dropped off with the sat
moving completely digital by 2024 davis
worries about student performance what
we have seen in the last two years are
a lot of students and actually the great
majority of students telling us that
they could not
learn as effectively online laura stone
a mother of three says tutoring helped
her kids learn at their own pace it
wasn't only the tutoring for the actual
exam
it was also sort of
kind of getting a little bit of guidance
snehashreidhar agrees saying tutoring
maximized her test taking strategies it
was definitely vital and helped me like
gain more confidence in how i attacked
and like approached standardized tests
ccsd also has a list of tutors for
resources visit your child's school
counselor or visit your school's website
mary jane balleza live local now